from calorie count to portion sizes we
wanted to find out all the differences
between McDonald's in the US and Italy
this is food
Wars drinks at McDonald's in Italy come
in three sizes 250 ml 400 Mill and 500
mL we're now going to measure a 500 mL
Coke to see if that's
true I think we're surpassing that it's
like just right below the 600 mark but
almost there so quite generous drinks in
the US also come in four sizes the extra
small which is 355 ml or 12 flu o the
small 474 ml or 16 flu o and the medium
621 ml or 21 flu ounces and the large
946 ml or 32 fluid ounces since we were
the ones that filled this up at the uh
restaurant and I I don't think we got it
all full up I'm going to go ahead and
fill this what I think is reasonable I
can't do to the top cuz the cap is
recessed okay 32 surely you just right
there's the 32 line not even close it's
closer to 24 than it is 32 so fries in
Italy come in three sizes the regular
which technically the small medium and
large here in America our fries come in
four sizes the kids which comes in the
Happy Meal look at this little guy a
little guy the small the medium and the
large all the food Wars heads watching
know that in the China episode our large
McDonald's fry was 175 G then Japan
episode our large McDonald's fry was 190
G so clearly there's some difference in
gramage depending on I don't know the
McDonald's will go to the scooper who
knows so we're going to weigh our large
right now ready
fantastic now let's go 185 not a bad
scoop we got a good scooper this time
seems pretty small actually what about
Mech nuggets in Italy you can get a bag
of four a box of six pieces nine pieces
and 20 pieces Claudia in the US our
McNuggets are available in these sizes
the four piece the six piece 10 piece 20
piece which you also have we go up one
more here in America our largest size
the 40 piece now if my calculations are
correct this is double your largest size
ionic Big Mac both countries have its
but we're going to compare ours to
Italy's by weighing it 226 G for us Big
Mac and here is an Italian Big Mac or E
Big Mac as is written here and we're
going to weigh it now 209
G here are all the items on the
McDonald's Italy menu that you won't
find in the US and here are all the
McDonald's menu items from the US you
won't find in Italy get a good look
Claudia let's start from the burgers we
have a bunch of Italian burgers that you
won't get in the US the first one we got
here is a chicken Big Mac oh right just
destroyed chicken Big Mac is that being
inverted is that supposed to look like
this
the cheese helps a little bit sauce as
well moving on we have a bacon Big Mac
yeah so there's two strips of bacon but
they're not quite big so it does look
like maybe it's just one that's been cut
in half we got a crispy MEC bacon which
is like cheeseburger double putty and
some bacon again a bit on the side it's
funny actually because you know growing
up I I thought that the crisy Bon was
the the iconic McDonald's item and it's
weird that it is actually an Italian
exclusive here are all the burgers in
the US that you can't get in Italy
starting down here the quarter pounder
with cheese it really is just a
cheeseburger that is a/4 pound of meats
it's a great go-to burger meat cheese
onions pickles ketchup and mustard and
if you want more meat get the Double
Quarter Pounder correct not the half
pounder the double qu Pounder with
cheese two patties more meat more
cheese it's a fantastic sandwich and
then we've got the first one of the my
selection range which is a range that
was um designed with Joe Bastianich he's
an American like TV personality and Chef
this one is spec and Asiago so yeah very
traditional spec is a type of cured meat
it's like a smoked ham yeah it's a
smoked ham from the north of Italy it's
actually very very nice just very salty
with that SMY flavor it's one of my
favorite and then we have Asiago which
is a cheese made pretty much in the same
area there's also mayo and zucchini in
there a bit dry I think you do taste the
cold cut the spec just brings that
saltiness smokiness very nice and the
cheese also is quite good yeah actually
I don't know if you've noticed but it is
much bigger than the others I mean we
can even take like a bacon Big M
even though it's supposed to have two
paties it is much bigger and then we
have another my selection uh Burger this
one is called my BBQ this one has got
barbecue sauce yes I can see it GAA
cheese and bacon and uh it's all topped
off with some balsamic vinegar it does
still have the same sort of fancy Patty
that we had before right and after this
very nice and fancy uh um Burgers we
have a glutenfree
burger oh wait why is it coming a bag
o yeah very o yeah not excited about
this just I don't like the bread uh I'm
sure you can find better gluten-free
bread there are so many around and if
you want
vegetables on your burger for some
strange reason you can get the quar
pound of a cheese deluxe with
lettuce and tomato and
Mayo hit like a pocket of mayonnaise in
that one that's kind of weird that
tastes great and he just want to go all
in on the meat you get a Double Quarter
Pounder with bacon look at
this
right it's really good I Al said and
surprise another thing in our menu you
guys don't have the McDouble McDonald's
has a double cheeseburger which is
double the meat double the cheese but
also Al there's a McDouble on the menu
what's the difference you ask well
McDouble only has one slice of cheese as
you can see from here on top you got
ketchup mustard and uh pickles no cheese
but the cheese is in between here get it
times you're toughens economy but get
the extra slice of cheese guys come on I
mean we're not robots here we got to
have some pleasure in our lives and I
think you should get that extra slice of
cheese absorb the cost of it it's
perfectly fine you're doing great come
on next one is another one of those my
selection it's a chicken avocado and
bacon
burger it's got a different bun this one
oh fancy all right yeah avocado is there
there's like cabbage bit look excited
about that and this one has kacho cavalo
cilano cheese I don't know we can call
this you know so St the cheese
St kacha cavalo comes from the same
family of mozzarella they're called
pasta fata cheeses and it's just
basically the way that you make cheese
uh when you split the milk into curds
and way it's made in a different way and
you could say that kacho cavalo is like
a Ned mozzarella so it's a very
versatile cheese that I think is not
very well known abroad So yeah thank you
McDonald's for making that uh a thing on
your menu so everybody can know about it
so here's the cheese that we were
talking about it's just almost a shame
it's been put there with like avocado
and this cabbage next on we've got
double chicken barbecue after seeing all
these big ones they do look quite small
and then we have a chicken burger this
one is different from a Mech chicken
because it has ciss uh sauce and no lce
I think this is glue it looks like
there's a type of glue that looks
exactly like that we also thought it'd
be fun to compare Happy Meals here's the
US One open up this box take a look
around I'm pretty sure this is Pokémon
this one comes with kid fries nuggets
which we got a six piece and our Pokémon
toy they get the six piece it's funny
like a six piece still seems kind of
like a lot for a kid Pokemon themed toys
coming at you these days what is this uh
okay so we got um Pikachu does this have
any value cuz there's like rare ones
like there's ones that have a lot of
value to them but any not the ones inest
ones right
card any value
we got
tanos yeah and of
course
sandaconda I'll go look on uh eBay after
this and see if uh these are worth
anything culturally I have no idea what
this is I don't know what this is a
thing no I have no idea
who I don't I don't remember any of
those
names
uh cha charazard card is this
card
charmar okay in a Happy Meal in Italy
you can find four items obviously there
is a drink uh then there is a main
course that could be either nuggets and
a hamburger and exclusive to Italy is a
chicken burger and a Mac toast which is
what we got today we're going to see
that in a moment then there is a side it
can either be fries or baby carrots and
a dessert this can be um either fresh
fruit ACL which is technically a drink
but it's a dessert here and Parmesan
here's our
Mose nice the surprise um of the day
yeah they just doing some Hot Wheels
collaboration so let's have a look at
what is it I don't know do you think I
can find a vest Pine here oh cute little
skateboard pink
one we also have one exclusive rub
option here in Italy it's a Mac WRA with
crispy chicken breast and Parmesan or
Parmesan orano it's made in
collaboration with jalo zafferano which
is um the number one recipe website in
Italy to be honest I think they could
have come up with a better recipe
maybe for the wrap the wrap does look
very sad just the actual bread chicken
looks okay Italy clearly has plenty of
exclusive chicken sandwich options but
we have a few of our own here namely the
MC Krispy and the spicy M Krispy and a
deluxe version of each sandwich let's
take a look it looks closer to a chicken
sandwich you would find at a Chick-fil-A
and then now uh Burger King has the
Chicken King I think McDonald's did all
the research that they do to release
this the mccrispy sandwich now as you
can tell it's just pickles on here a
crispier more natural looking piece of
fried chicken
and no sauce does it always have no
sauce I don't like that I don't like a
place that gives you food in like
assembly
requirements for the most part I just
get the sandwich the way it's supposed
to be so just put your own sauce in it
it's like no you put it on here's a
deluxe
it it yay that has mayo whoa this to me
is like yeah do this every time this
should just be the sandwich I
don't if you're like me and you want to
spice it
up they had the spicy come on they were
their spicy sauce on here somewhere then
of course they got the spicy deluxe
which of course has spicy sauce and all
veggies in there so yeah McDonald's
still a contender in the chicken
sandwich game I feel now we're on to the
exclusive sides here in Italy the first
one that we got is cheesy fries the same
fry just with a bit more bacon we go
here yeah cheddar and bacon this is like
I don't know a very sad Italian take on
ptin on the menu next for sides we've
got pancerote
so actually very excited about these
because ooh they are a pancero they are
from my hometown body in the south of
Italy the main difference is that
usually pancerote like the traditional
ones they are this big they're like
usually pretty wide it's like a main
meal Panero normally they have tomatoes
and mozzarella is the most common
filling but INB uh again where they are
from uh you can get them with ground
beef mozzarella and cooked ham these are
actually my favorit I used to go and get
them after school um you know that's
just they are the perfect
snack quite good actually feeling is
okay but I think a real pancero when you
bite into it basically all the feeling
should almost come out it should like
pop you know like the first reaction
when you eat a panat this is like and
then just sort of put your hand here and
just avoid a complete mess this brings
us to the next snack which is parano
reano or parmesan this is one the most
counterfeit cheeses in the world so in
Italy but also in Europe because of this
whole protection thing anything that's
called even parmesan not the real name
parmo is in fact the real thing so at
least we're safe on that side having
said that I think um most of the
parmeson parmo that you will
find around you know in supermarkets is
like been aged for the bare minimum
which is 12 months so it is good it is
the real Fame but if you can choose just
have something that's been aged for a
bit longer I think in Italy we do eat a
lot of cheese as a snack like as it is
and I do have um definitely memories of
like me coming back from school you know
and then just in the afternoon grabbing
some cheese off the fridge and like
having a couple of slices or even more
than that um I think my mom still does
that so sorry for exposing you
Mom love it over here we got another
exclusive there are actually three
salads on the menu uh one is just a
plain salad one is a salad with um
tomatoes and then we got one with crispy
chicken breast and Parmesan we could
also select a dressing and we added
olive oil um you could also get a tiny
bottle of balsamic vinegar or just
vinegar we actually have no exclusive
sides in the US every side option in our
menu can also be found in Italy I will
say though I love that they have a stick
of cheese as a side kind of like a
pallet cleanser I would love that I
would love to snack on cheese I love
snacking on cheese we should have more
cheese is what I'm trying to say we can
bring it back with the sauces it's time
for sauce talk Italy Edition la la sace
talk that had to offend somebody sauce
talk we have several exclusive sauces
here in the United States including
spicy buffalo and then we have Ranch
honey mustard sweet and sour now I have
two because one is from the movie Loki
apparently and of course you just get
honey uh of all these i' probably go
sweet and
sour but barbecue which they do have is
my favorite we have one exclusive sauce
in Italy which is spicy mustard sauce
yeah yeah it is a bit spicy not so much
though doesn't numb your tongue I think
actually it has a sweet aftertaste for
some reason for the early risers there
are plenty of exclusive breakfast items
at the US McDonald's and they're all
Savory now first thing I'm want to talk
about are the biscuits I'm not the
person to describe American biscuits to
the rest of the world they should have
hired a poet this is the bacon egg and
cheese biscuit but you can get a biscuit
version of any meat or cheese
combination that you want in the middle
here though Italy Claudia everyone look
at what I'm about to show you you know
what pancakes are you know what syrup is
you obviously know what breakfast
sandwiches are this right here is a
McGriddle and they replace the buns with
this these bun pancakes this is a
pancake Italy a pancake these here and
they somehow injected syrup in them so
it's not like syrup like a sauce it's
just like already syrup somehow and it
is Savory and sweet at the same time
time it is so delicious it's a McGriddle
it's fantastic I love these this is a
bacon egg and cheese McGriddle but once
again you can get it in any various
sausage egg Andor cheese combination
that you want MC riddles check them out
I am the MC rdle number one fan over
here in the OG breakfast sandwich this
is the Egg McMuffin they got the big
breakfast with or without Hot Cakes I
went with hot cakes you got eggs bacon
pancakes English muffin this thing's
fantastic
and if you want to just get hot cakes
and sausage you can also do that and
each order of Pancakes comes with our
hot cakes syrup I think an unsung hero
of the McDonald's breakfast menu been a
fan of this for years it is the sausage
breakfast burrito now let's be honest
Italy in case you're wondering this in
no way represents an actual burrito I
want to make that perfectly clear I
would not put this in the same category
as any sort of burrito breakfast or
otherwise but it's its own thing and I
think it is
fantastic it is in a flower
tortilla scrabbled eggs sausage yes I
know Peppers
cheese and the secret
weapon is this they Mexican style salsa
again there is
nothing authentically Mexican about this
but it tastes great this was a go-to for
years I could put away about four of
these uh McDonald's also does offer
oatmeal specifically fruit and maple
oatmeal moving on the Italian McDonald's
also sells breakfast items we've
got that's super sad we got scrambled
eggs with bacon and a muffin and bread
which what does look more more like a
muffin and then we have a Mech muffin
with bacon and egg yeah Italians don't
really have savory breakfast it's
definitely um a habit like you just
associate breakfast with sweet items all
right the US also has their own
exclusive M Cafe
items where' they
go the McDonald's is near our studio did
not have the maafe food
items
McDonald's in Italy has really made an
effort with the me cafe uh menu items
and there are really a lot of items on
the menu here so let's start from the
croissants we've got quite a few on the
menu I think this one here uh because
you can see a little bit of brown this
is the Coco one with sour
dough pretty safe to eat this is the
plain one does look more like a French
St Cel nice layers in there as well some
air over
here it's quite hard to tell but there
is a subtle subtle layer of jam this is
berries and cereal so the dough it looks
it's a little bit stiffer
and yeah does smell a little
bit more like cereals same amount of jam
that as in the others not not very
generous actually I think this one is
the last one that we got so it's the
custard this looks
like we have a bit more in there
obviously it's hard to tell because the
custard is the same color as the um as
the dough has kind of turned the dough
Yellow Nice lots of lemon in there
another pastry option that you can get
is this cream braid
uh this is quite a typical thing as well
in Italy like you do get this kind of
pastries you can get them also Savory in
like different regions of Italy let's
see if they were generous with the cream
here yeah I'll say
so I prefer this cream in Italy you can
also get uh some cakes we have
tiramisu which is yeah a traditional
Italian thing but not a breakfast item
like I wouldn't really have breakfast
with tiramisu I know you guys want to
hear the opinion of an Italian so we're
going to try this Tiramisu and see if
it's
proper yeah it's quite good actually we
do have other Cakes as well we have this
one which is Tora de Lona in Italian um
and that literally translates to
Grandma's cake in English this one has
lemon custard and pine
nuts I think it's a bit of a joke that
this is actually called Grandma's cake
just because you know every Italian
grandma that's good in the kitchen will
be able to make something like a 100
times better than this we've got a
strawberry cheesecake let's move on to
this thre layer chocolate cake it's like
an absolute
Beast it's a bit too much I wouldn't
have this for breakfast like and then we
have a few more items here at the me
cafe in Italy we have have a marshmallow
dut which looks like the most artificial
thing I've ever seen then we've got a
Nutella muffin it is true that Italians
love Nutella and they eat it all the
time you know again when I was a child
my parents used to hide
it sad and the last item that we've got
is uh macaroons we have chocolate
macaroons raspberry macaroons and
pistachos macaroons or pistachio as we
do say
here
oh the inside is like dangerously green
they don't taste so much like pistacho
to be honest desserts McDonald's us we
have these exclusives St down here the
baked apple pie the day they stopped
frying these is the day I stopped eating
them now they pulling this with like
trying to make it look like it's a
homemade pastry it's t not this this was
just spit out of an AI oven
[Music]
machine one a second no human I'm the
first human hand to touch this also
chocolate chip cookies they come in
orders of one three the trilogy or a
tote of 13 one good thing about the
McDonald's we went to today is the
McFlurry machine was totally working and
I got this one the M&M's McFlurry we use
the mini M&M's which are better than
regular M&M's I don't know why they just
are Sundays Sundays Sundays maybe my
favorite as a kid the caramel
sunde oh that's my childhood right there
and get a fudge one as well for Italian
exclusive desserts we have a pistachios
Mech flurry then a Bachi perugina
McFlurry Bachi perugina are very popular
uh chocolates they are made in peruja
which is in the center of Italy a town
in the center and here we have a coffee
sunde it's quite nice that they actually
gave us the espresso so that we can make
our own a bit like an aato in a way the
other Sundays are caramel berries
another Bachi perugina again and fatte
which is basically the Italian version
of
vanilla
o nice yeah now on to the cold drink
options uh starting down here all the
soda options you get here in the US of
course we have way more than Italy
starting with Dr P pepper oh come
here so fantastic Diet Coke
no this completely unnatural looking
thing is high SE orange lava blast it's
not carbonated but it's also not juice I
can't explain it it's high se you can
also get a sweet tea and an unsweetened
iced tea at McDonald's what I did feel
like getting was this the Frozen Fanta
blue raspberry
oh God it's so sweet and so serpy don't
drink this don't give it to children
don't have it ever I also have a Coke
version frozen Coke also don't bother
lemonade though so we found out that
lemonade in America is the least
different from Lemonade in the UK again
this is not carbonated it's not really
juice it's something different I don't
know what lemonade is like in Italy
but oh man so tart and so good on to
coffee drink or should I say cold coffee
drinks from here to here understand
there's not a thing in Italy which I
think is hilarious this giant glass
right here is iced coffee you can also
get it caramel flavored or french
vanilla flavored I went with black the
Ace of Spades right
here oh man they do something with their
coffee there they do something where it
tastes like it's really roasted I mean
I'm sure it's not you also get a ice
latte but this over here is a frappe you
get a mocha frappe or a caramel frappe
basically if you're an adult and you
want a milkshake you get a Frapp you can
also get smoothies at McDonald's we have
a mango pineapple smoothie and a
strawberry banana smoothie in Italy we
have a few exclusive drinks let's start
with the cold options we have lip and IC
tea both in lemon and Peach then we have
some fruit juices we have PE AE which is
very popular here in Italy um it's
should be very orange is a mix of orange
carrots and lemon yeah very orange and
it's named AER which is a c e after the
three vitamins that these fruits or like
vegetables I guess the carrots contains
and then we got Pitch fruit juice and
here are our McDonald's hot coffee
drinks coffee right Italy all right we
get it we went a little overboard with
our coffee drinks here in America and
McDonald's of course is no different you
can get
a caramel macchiato a caramel
cappuccino why are we doing so much
caramel stuff in America right ah
caramel latte you can also get it in
vanilla don't you can also get a mocha
latte we have a uh premium roast coffee
as I said before I don't know what
they're doing in McDonald's
but I like the coffee but you can also
get finally a black hot tea what is this
the
UK the hot drinks exclusive to Italy are
obviously the king of hot drinks
espresso uh then we've got a Moroccan
coffee which is not Moroccan in the
sense of it's not Moroccan style coffee
uh but weirdly enough and to be honest I
never really understood this it's named
after a type of Moroccan leather that
looks this color honestly it's like an
espresso with some milk and then we got
ginen coffee and barley coffee we
technically shouldn't really be C coffee
because it contains no coffee it has
just barley and this is like an
alternative for people that cannot drink
coffee and uh they still want to have
something like a little espresso after
lunch yeah it smells very
Cally I don't know I'm not a big fan and
then we got just a standard uh latte
macato this is like the closest thing
you would get to a latte
that you will find here in Italy so it's
just a lot of milk with a bit of coffee
and some foam at a
top in Italy a Big Mac will cost you
$610 in dollars that's about
$676 a Big Mac in the US will cost you
$629 it's a 3% price increase from Italy
to the US what if you turn that into a
combo in Italy a small Big Mac meal with
medium fries and a medium drink will
cost you
8.90 and that's
$986 does a combo meal make a difference
in the US a medium Big Mac combo meal
over here will cost you
$142 you can also save some money if you
buy in bulk here in Italy you can get a
two person Mac menu which includes two
Big Macs two large portions of fries two
large uh coca-colas six nuggets gets for
€8 in the US we only do Big Mac combo
meals as mentioned before so in order to
get the same order in Italy you would
have to order two Big Mac Meals plus six
nuggets on the side it would cost around
$36 which in Italy is about
33 pricewise I think they are definitely
better value than other fast food chains
well notably Five Guys I know that one
is has a reputation for being quite
expensive but I think the burger is like
half the price for the
I think that was more than 3 years 3
years something which honestly for like
three of those as a side it is a little
bit sad but again I grew up in the town
of panarotti and um I used to have like
a full one this size for like two that
was 15 years ago so maybe now it would
translate into something like maybe five
or six Once Upon a Time McDonald's was
the cheaper option it was a lot of food
for not a lot of money as many people
probably pointed out on social media
this food is no longer inexpensive it's
not expensive maybe because of the
competition maybe because of inflation
probably because of corporate greed
McDonald's and most fast food I find is
not a good value
anymore let's compare some items to see
what the nutrition is of McDonald's food
a sandwich that exist in both countries
and is theoretically identical is the
Big Mac in the US a big Mac contains 590
calories 34 G of total fats 46 G of
carbs and 9 g of sugar how about an
Italian Big Mac one of those here
contains 9 calories um of these there
are 26 G of total fat 42 G of carbs of
which 90 G are sugars and then there are
920 mg of sodium what if we made it a
combo meal starting with the fries a
medium fry in the US contains 320
calories 15 G of total fat 43 G of carbs
no sugar and 260 migrs of sodium while a
medium fries in Italy contains 330
calories 16 G of total fat 41 G of carbs
of which 0.4 G are sugars and 212 mg of
sodium and let's add the medium cocon to
the mix it contains 210 calories no fat
56 carbs 56 of those are sugar and 55
Mig of sodium that's funny there's salt
in the soda we'll do the same here
here's what's inside a medium Coke in
Italy it's 168 calories 0 g of fat 42 G
of carbs 42 g of sugar so it's like all
sugar and 0 g of sodium that leaves the
total for the Italian meal at this 1,07
calories 42 2 G of fat 125 G of carbs
51.4 G of sugars and 1,00 132 mg of
sodium while in the us the total ends up
looking like
this let's talk about ingredients now
McDonald's Italy shares a lot of
information actually about its
ingredients uh that's because the
majority of the items on the menu are
made with
100% uh Italian products the beef like
the one that's used in the Big Mac is
Source from over 15,000 different Farms
are located in Northern Italy around the
regions of Lombardy uh where we are now
and uh the capital of which is Milan and
pedmont there are apples from South Tio
which is where spec is made just at the
border with Austria and just to give
some recognition to the southern regions
because I'm from there uh so no bias at
all we've got got some apricots from the
um vuan National Park so in Campania and
Sicilian oranges and when we talk about
dop this red label here is what you're
looking for it's a label that's used for
a lot of traditional products around the
EU and that means that they have to be
made with certain following certain
specific standards most of the time in a
very artisanal way but that also means
that certain products like parmesan
cannot be made outside of a specific
area that has to do with the climate so
for example for cheese the main argument
is that it's a raw milk cheese and in
raw milk cheeses you do taste what the
cows eat so obviously the grass has a
different taste depending on where you
are in the world but we do have some
American sourc ingredients for
McDonald's the potatoes used for our
fries are grown in Washington at 100
circles Farm which is owned by Bill
Gates apparently they grow the potatoes
and Circle so big you can see it from
space the potatoes are then cut into
fries at 70 mph which is faster than a
cheetah that's the unit of
measurement that natural secret
ingredient to McDonald's fries is beef
flavoring which they've been doing since
the 1950s want to see there's any
differences in the US and the Italy's
Big Mac these are all the ingredients in
a Big Mac in the us all together that's
68 ingredients to make up a Big Mac
that's a lot 28 of those ingredients are
in the bun which quite a lot for bread
the Big Mac sauce also has a lot of
ingredients 26 alog together and it
seems like we added a lot of relish to
ours which bulks out the ingredients in
Italy there are 54 ingredients in a Big
Mac here they
are we only have 20 ingredients in the
band actually because we don't fortify
the flour like you do in the US Our Big
Mac sauce has 15 ingredients which is
still nine less than the uh us Big Mac
Joe most most of the other ingredients
are similar but we don't have as many
colorings or thickeners as you do in the
US some of the ingredients listed in our
Us big Mech sauce caught our attention
so we want to explain what they are
first up propylene glycol alginate is
derived from brown seaweed and is a
thickener used in foods to give it
smooth natural texture next up we got
hydrolized corn which is a plant protein
from corn or Maze and is used as a
flavoring for its Umami taste so citrate
helps cheese to melt without becoming
greasy I did grow up uh with with
McDonald's I definitely celebrated a
couple birthdays over there I had my uh
share of like happy meals with like lots
of little girly toys it is definitely
considered healthier than other fast
food chains because it has been around
for quite some time but also obviously
because he has italianized a lot over
the years incorporating things like
parmesan or like traditional cheeses and
cold cats or just appealing a little bit
more to the taste of like Italians I
have been to stores in the US and the UK
um and Italian McDonald's seem I don't
know a little bit fancier it's
everywhere and made burgers and fries
and sodas to go the most popular meal in
the country and then how many places
followed suit with Burger King and
Wendy's and all the like and now we got
chicken sandwich version on like a fried
chick
McDonald's McDonald ified the entire
country and the world McDonald's is like
Nike or Christianity it's
everywhere the number one it's like the
mascot of the show okay and is it name
Pokemon yeah no PO is the Tye animal oh